today we're going to be speaking with
jeff duncan who's the republican
lieutenant governor of georgia and also
author of the new book gop 2.0 how the
2020 election can lead a better way
forward for america's conservative party
uh it's great to have you on i
appreciate it
yeah thanks for the opportunity
so okay i mean where to start right
georgia has been at the center of uh
significant political controversy we now
know about the various phone calls and
requests to put it lightly that were
made by former president trump um when
it comes to the results of the 2020
georgia election i mean is it
give us your sense of
the direction that the republican party
has gone relative to where you would
like to see it as a conservative party
yeah there's definitely chaos on the
battlefield for sure and certainly we're
watching that play out in georgia and
i think georgia is just a microcosm of
what's what's playing out all over the
country uh you know i'm one of those
people that i'm i'm hardwired to be a
conservative i grew up that way went to
college that way started my first
business raised my family i just believe
in the conservative principles
and so it pains me to watch
the inability to win elections because
of a stylistic because of personalities
not because of our policies
that's painful to watch and that's kind
of the process in the tug of war that
we're in right now
as a republican party that's really what
drove me to write gop 2.0 it's not
really any sort of watered-down
you know policy positions as a
conservative it's just about a better
approach to deliver those policy
positions to america
so
did you vote for donald trump in 2020
i did
i did you know uh
uh i voted for him in 2016. i voted for
him in 2020 i probably fit myself in
that category of tens of millions of of
republicans that did the same thing that
you know really really applauded the the
conservative wins over those four years
but just hard to explain to even my own
kids i talk about this in the book quite
a bit my three boys really shaped a lot
of
uh kind of my positions just in raising
them with my wife
it was hard to explain you know the
tweets that went out you know i'd spend
all this time telling my kids you know
hey be careful on what you do on social
media you know and then how do i explain
you know the former president doing what
he did
how did you explain how did you explain
voting for him then
yeah so interesting i talked a lot about
it in story you know mine was you know i
as i compared the divide ideas and plans
forward really what i explained or at
least i rationalized in my mind is
really what's playing out right now with
joe biden you know i mean nobody this is
a non-partisan answer to this nobody
agrees in my my mind that the
afghanistan handoff was the way it
should have been handled uh the way you
were dealing with inflation the southern
border the only person i mean everybody
believes in border security uh except
for joe biden so i put those elements
against what donald trump had done as a
conservative and
and i pulled that i pulled the uh the
the ballot for president trump
what exactly would trump have done
differently on afghanistan because he
was actually asked on a newsmax
interview he couldn't articulate a
single thing he would have done
differently
yeah i think looking back uh you know
now in you know the hindsight of 2020
monday morning quarterback looks at he
didn't really have an exit strategy out
of there as thorough as i probably
thought he did
but i hope
that there was enough conservative
leadership in his administration that
would have given him better advice than
what joe biden did and how he executed
uh the the
the exit out of afghanistan right that
would be my hope but it's only it's only
hypothetical yeah no because it seems
since it's the first thing you mentioned
that you're not pleased with in terms of
biden
but then trump can't articulate what he
would have done differently and you sort
of can either other than to say it's a
hope you have it doesn't it it's
interesting to me that that's not
stylistic like at first you said it you
know that they're they're mostly
stylistic
differences with trump but uh but policy
was where
you you would like to see the policies
enacted but then like on afghanistan
it's not really clear the policy would
have been any different so i'm trying to
understand sort of whether your
disagreement is just on style or whether
it's policy as well
well we can split hairs all day long
there's a president that's in office and
made the decisions and his name's joe
biden there's a former president that's
not in office that didn't make those
decisions on exiting afghanistan the
reality is i would have hoped that more
military minds would have made those
realistic decisions and they would have
had more timely thoughtful consideration
for those that helped support our
military those that were
fully expected to be helped through any
sort of military transition or exit out
of the out of the country my hope is any
president whether a democrat or
republican would have been more
thoughtful for that but that didn't
happen and i think that's the same thing
that we're watching play out with the
southern border i believe in border
security it's one of the things i talk a
lot about in the book i think
republicans have totally dropped the
ball including former president trump on
immigration we spend all this energy
kind of fear-mongering about the
southern border yeah and we built 460
miles of border wall out of a what two
thousand mile border or more um and and
the reason why i think we've dropped the
ball is we're only having a singular
focused conversation about a big issue
like immigration uh border security but
the the real conversation in addition
has got to be the 16 million
undocumented folks that are here many of
which we have been full force allowing
them to be embedded in our communities
and in our economy and we got to have a
real conversation about that that to me
is an area of opportunity for
republicans to join ranks with some of
the folks on the other side of the aisle
to have those real conversations and i
talk a lot about that
i'm i'm curious uh this is sort of kind
of like uh
it's a sanity check of sorts
when during the 2016 campaign
where where you did end up voting for
donald trump when he said during his
first term he would build a wall across
all 2000 miles and mexico would pay for
it did you believe that for a second
i did
i'm sorry did you say you did not
i did not you did not oh okay
why do you think so many people did
believe that when he said it when it was
so obviously going to not happen
well i think that's the riddle that
we're trying to solve right now as the
republican party is you know how can we
get people away and like this isn't just
a republican problem it's a democrat
problem too
you know america is addicted to 10
second sound bites we're making massive
political decisions and putting our
support behind folks in short clips
uh and certainly gop 2.0 is really
trying to build a much more thoughtful
thorough
plan of attack on some of these big
issues ones that aren't in about 280
characters on twitter or about some
slogan called build a wall what really
drew the most higher for the former
president uh to to me specifically
during the 10 weeks of you know my very
intense rebuttal of the conspiracy
theories and the fraudulent you know the
real fraud was talking about fraud in
the election cycle here in georgia
so
my my major pushback really started when
i said look build a wall is a great
project name but it's not an immigration
policy we as republicans need to grasp
on to a a serious immigration policy and
start to move forward uh you know i i
that really drew the ire of the former
president and really started a a
visceral downhill spiral on whatever
relationship that was out there yeah so
like what happened during those days
between
election day 2020
where we ultimately learned the margin
of victory for joe biden in georgia
subsequently the phone calls i need brad
raffensberger to find me 11 780 votes
give me a break like what what was what
were you doing at that time who were you
talking to what were the conversations
like
yeah so you know i i literally within
days of the election and all of this
kind of rumor mill starting that there
was fraud and whatnot i i dove head
first into the details i talked to the
governor's office i talked to the
secretary of state uh and his entire
team i talked to the attorney general
and really the feedback i was getting is
jeff there's there's no signs of any
sort of systemic fraud there's nothing
coming in other than just wildly placed
social media posts and and wild
allegations starting to flow in from the
trump administration
so i started to get as quickly as i
could get on tv for for two reasons one
is i didn't want any sort of runaway
rumor to take over the control the
narrative that that we can run a fair
legal you know legal election here in
georgia and two i was trying to protect
the runoff process from two conservative
u.s senators that were now engaged in a
runoff and
unfortunately we we know how that turned
out if you're a conservative
so i hit the tv i probably did i don't
know what the number is 60 70 80 100
national television interviews and inter
uh radio and music or a print interviews
and and i spoke up against it i was one
of the first folks that said
unfortunately i'm going to have to say
joe biden is the president-elect
and and
almost instantly drew ire from not only
the former president
but also from you know
people all over all over the country uh
we ended up you know receiving threats
as a family we had 24-hour security i
mean it was it was an intense 10 weeks
of you know simply
you know just telling the troops
and one of the surprising things for me
was and one of the motivating factors
behind writing the the book gop 2.0
was
you know i thought i was walking out
singing as part of a republican choir
but the reality was i was singing a solo
for far too long
when the facts simply lined up that
there was no fraud there was no systemic
issues going on donald trump got beat
and he's the one who missed the layup
and as a republican i hold him
accountable for not doing the things he
needed to do to win
was there behind the scenes
any consideration
among brian kemp brad raffensberger and
other election officials of actually
trying to do what donald trump was
asking to have done
so i'll only speak for myself and the
answer is no there was no way i was
going to move my feet this job is not
worth lying for
and i certainly wouldn't lie to 11
million georgians
some of them who who wanted you know to
see the scenario changed but uh i
certainly never heard of any comment i
never had a conversation with any of the
other statewide elected officials that
that ever appeared to me that they were
considering it but i'd encourage you to
get their opinion on that sure so i
guess as
opinions aside as far as you know
no absolutely as far as i know there was
never a consideration uh between the
governor the speaker the secretary of
state and myself to to take into
consideration because look there was
multiple avenues going
at this point there were you know the
the former president wanted to have a
special session to send a different set
of electorates we wanted to have
you know just all types of different
scenarios were playing out that just
really weren't feasible
do you think that
the craziness that took place involving
these fraud claims between november and
the date of the special elections for
the senate which i think was january 5th
do you think that contributed to both
republican senators losing their races
yeah 100 percent
absolutely uh and it was unfortunate uh
i don't claim to be smarter than anybody
by any stretch of the imagination i'm
just a retired baseball player for the
most part but i could see it coming from
a mile away
when they by by default hired donald
trump as their campaign manager during
the runoff
that was the beginning to the end
georgians wanted to be reminded of their
conservative policies and and positions
that they stood for they they you know
georgia fell in love with their business
acumen and their ability to articulate
jobs and you know national security and
all those things that really kind of are
the tenets of why you know we wanted
them there and why the governor
hand-selected kelly leffler to represent
johnny isaac since the the remainder of
his term
they forgot to do that and uh
unfortunately donald trump got his hooks
in him
and you know just made it all about him
and his conspiracy theories do you think
that trump's actions uh in terms of uh
the influence campaign and the phone
calls
might have been criminal
so i'm not an attorney i i told you i'm
a recovering baseball player
but based on conversations you have
there
yeah so look i i think i think i'll
start with they were absolutely
inappropriate
uh and they were disgusting uh whether i
was a whatever you know party
affiliations were associated with it
they were just inappropriate and uh i
know that there's investigations going
on and they're gonna certainly get to
the bottom of what their opinions are
from those legal uh investigations but i
don't have i don't have the legal acumen
to split hairs and know if it was
illegal or not it was inappropriate for
sure fair uh one of the the criticisms
i've had of the republican party of late
as someone who's not a republican is
that
the focus on policy has become close to
zero and the most prominent republicans
right now that that get headlines
federally are getting headlines by
saying that they don't want to wear
masks or they don't want people to have
to get vaccinated or
they're taking a stance against critical
race theory or
fauci's trying to cancel christmas or
now it's halloween i guess fox did a
bunch of segments yesterday about
halloween maybe getting cancelled
do you think that this is a direction
that's good for just just without
evaluating it morally for winning races
for winning elections is it good to
focus on the culture stuff instead of
policy
absolutely not i spend a lot of time in
the book talking about it uh because
look at the end of the day we're all
supposed to be running for these offices
because we want to we want to be in a
position of leadership right and there's
no leadership to be found in all these
short-term sugar high issues i talked
about in the book what i refer to as my
pet project policy empathy and tone
really is the strategy to approve all of
those as a meaningful way to win back
the white house in 24. and on the policy
front yeah we we have literally
forgotten to remind america of the
policies that we as republicans are good
at just like you mentioned europe you're
you're part of the you know you're
you're a democrat uh i'm not a democrat
i'm i'm on the left but i'm not a
democrat
okay okay so you're on the left so
there's certain issues that you think
the left are better at right that's your
personal position sure well i think
there's some things that americans think
that republicans are better at we just
have totally forgotten to remind people
of those policies that we're good at and
we've also forgotten the ability to
understand that we can lead on some of
these big issues i talked about
immigration a second ago
let's talk about health care right it is
a it is an issue right for the picking
to talk about something other than we
hate obamacare
more you know more at 11. right you know
we need to put more on the bone there we
need to talk about how we center health
care
uh away from the government and on to
the small business owners how do we
empower small business owners who by the
way are the bulk of the employers in
this country to be able to compete with
big companies and with government
programs to be able to offer affordable
health insurance to their employees and
to be able to entice people to come to
work
uh instead of just going to the mailbox
to receive those there's so many
solutions that republicans can come up
with healthcare but we got to be willing
to talk about them and not these
sideshows and these distraction elements
and these shiny objects that that really
kind of just run two-day news cycles and
then we then we gotta hurry up find the
next one yeah you mentioned 2024 and
taking back the white house obviously
before that we have a midterm election
in 2022
do you think that it helps
your
um
sort of i don't know that i call it a
side but your approach
to the republican party is it helped or
hindered if folks like marjorie taylor
greene and lauren beaubert and madison
cawthorne get re-elected next year
uh so i don't i don't know
the only person i really know in that
mix uh that i know well is marjorie
taylor green and certainly if we have
more marge retailer greens in uh
congress uh we we we're in trouble as
republicans right that's a problem right
and and i certainly have made no no
qualms about it that i think she's
destructive to our state i think she's
destructive to our party i think she a
person like her is destructive to our
country uh and so it's not just enough
to get republican leadership we got to
have the right republicans that care
about the long-term viability of
conservative leadership and conservative
policies uh that aren't about little
side shows and press conferences and and
whatnot um you know our tone matters you
know i talked about the pet project
policy empathy and tone
our tone is so important if simply
donald trump had a better tone you know
if down the stretch he
he he kind of became an adult and said
you know what i'm i'm the leader of the
free world and i'm going to use the next
100 days to really put on display my
leadership style i'm going to take my
business resume on how i can coordinate
the vaccine distribution how i can
manage international affairs how i can
manage an economy that continues to whip
solve and y'all just judge me by what i
do not by what i said right just that
better authoritative tone would have
made mountains of difference i think it
would have probably won him the election
but of course he couldn't get out of his
own way and and i talked about that in
the book with several one-on-one
conversations with him uh in the back of
the beast uh that really kind of led me
to led me to see
that smell in the air of defeat you
could sense even as as close to the
election as two days before donald trump
came down to georgia for a rally in rome
georgia and i was there as one of the
speakers and and this was this was
eye-opening to me i spent a lot of time
in the book talking about this i made a
statement because i was trying to win
the suburbs i knew where we had where we
had to win
was was convince the suburbs that he was
worthy of four more years and i knew it
was going to be close and i made a
statement in kind of closing of my
five-minute speech i said you know what
our policies are so good as republicans
they even help the people that don't
vote for us
and i got booed
i literally got booed by a sea of 30 000
make america great hats
because i was willing to say that our
policies are so good to help the people
that don't vote for us too and that was
an eye-opener to me that one the
president was out there campaigning a
hundred miles away from the suburbs and
two
there was such a visceral reaction to
even looking at trying to help the other
side or even trying to build bridges or
expand the size of the tent yeah even
two days before the election the smell
was in the air not just in georgia but
all over the country yeah that's a
definite red flag no no question no
question there the book is gop 2.0 how
the 2020 election can lead to a better
way forward for america's conservative
party we've been speaking with the
book's author jeff duncan who's the
lieutenant governor of georgia really
appreciate your time and your
perspective today
yeah thanks for the opportunity i really
i really appreciate